اخذ المتحدث باسم الحكومه الافغانيه بمقتل
ثلاثه مهاجمين واصابه اثنين من الرعايه
الاجانب في هجوم على مجمع سكني للصينيين
وسط العاصمه الافغانيه
صدفا المدخل الرئيسيه للمجمع وان حريقه
اندلع داخله جلال اشتباكات بين القوه
الافغانيه الخاصه والمجرمين
هل هناك اي معلومات جديده في ما يتعلق
بالجهه التي نفذت هذا الهجوم
نعم اولا حسب المستشفى الطوارئ هنا في
العاصمه الافغانيه كابول ان هناك ثلاثه
قاتله ما عدا ثلاثه مهاجمين انتحارينا
الذين اعلن عنهم المتحدث باسم حركه
الحكومه الافغانيه مجاهد ان هناك 21 من
المصابين نحن لا نعرف بالضبط يعني جنسيات
هؤلاء ولكن المجمع بالكامل هو المجمع
الاعتبار الصينيين هنا في العاصمه
الافغانيه كابول وهناك مصدر امني اخر
يتحدث عن اصابه 95 بينهم نساء من حيث يوجد
في هذا المجمع السكني هناك مكاتب لشركات
صينيه وهناك مسؤولين وهناك صحفيين الذين
يزون افغانستان ينزلون في هذا المجمع حتى
الان لم يجيها مسؤوليه هذا الهجوم ولكن
هناك مصادر في الحكومه الحاليه تشير الى
تنظيم الدوله بانه يقف وراء هذا الحادث
وان عمليه الاشتباكات بين الطرفين استمرت
هنا في العاصمه الافغانيه كابول اكثر من
ثلاث ساعات حتى وصلت القوات الخاصه الاف
وتمكنت يعني بعد ثلاث ساعات من تمشيط هذه
المنطقه لان المصادر الامنيه التي كانت
موجوده هنا بان المهاجمين الذين يقتحموا
هذا المجمع السكني يعني ودعوا للغام في كل
طابق فكان هناك يعني عمليه صعبه حتى يتمكن
هؤلاء من التنظيف او يبطال هذه الغابه
التي كانت موجوده في كل طابق وهذا يعني
المجمع يتكون من سبعه طوابق وهذا كان هناك
حريق جرىء تفجيرات الانتحاريه بحيث هؤلاء
الثلاثه هم عندما انتهى معهم الذخيره
الحيه فهم فجروا انفسهم وما زال هناك
القوات الامنيه موجوده لتنشيط المنطقه
وايضا المناطق المجاوره لهذا المجمع
السكني في كابول هنا
حمد الله محمد شكرا جزيلا لك